euh on va revenir sur ce dossier
agression drogue condition de détention
pierre boton revient sur l'envers du
décor des présons Français il était déjà
venu nous voir il y a de ça une
quinzaine de jours c'était très très
très fort mais là il revient avec des
images euh puisque il y a un doc qui va
être donc ce soir qui va être sur My
canal dès ce soir son documentaire
dedans diffusé sur Canal doc est
disponible donc ce soir après l'émission
sur My canal dans ce do qui revient donc
sur l'envers du décor du décor des
prisons françaises agression drog
condition détenenstion il nous a donné
quelques extraits en exclusivité vous
allez voir et donc là il revient avec
des images c'est très très très très
très très fort je pense ça va être un
énorme carton regardez le premier
extrait on vous dévoile en exclusivité
regardez il y a des téléphones il y a de
la drogue et des fois ils vont trouver
des Coutau céramique il y a des piscines
gonflables il y a des climes tout
s'achète c'est simple tout s'achète même
moi en tant que détenu je sais même pas
d'où ils on ils ont pu trouver ça là ils
m'ont mis un brouilleur regardez
j'arrive à communiquer non j'ai une
espèce de boîtier en fait que je mets à
l'extérieur et qui me dégage la wifi et
que j' utilise la wifi là merci Pierre
boton d'être avec nous on rappelle qui
est Pierre boton pierre a été condamné
deux fois pour abus de BI sociaux une
fois dans les années 90 puis une seconde
fois en 2020 c'est un génie he Pier que
tu nous disis la dernière fois ça que
j'aime moi j'adore ta franchise tu nous
as dit ouais jeis fait je l'ai refait en
2020 c'est ça alors pierre c'est le mec
le plus franc que je connaisse c'est
c'est ça que j'aime chez toi ça va mon
pierre ouais c'est très bien en forme là
maintenant tu es bien ou très bien là tu
es tranquille alors il y a le doc qui
passe ce soir je sais que tu as passé
beaucoup de temps pour faire ce doc
c'est projet je sais que tu m'en parles
depuis des semaines et des semaines ce
projet et là ça y est c'est ce soir donc
vous allez pouvoir découvrir ce doc qui
va être je vous dis un énorme carton il
a passé énormément de temps Pierre a
travaillé
là-dessus chaque épisode de votre
documentaire commence par un message
expliquant l'administration a refusé de
participer à ce film et vous a refusé de
tourner en prison pourquoi ils ont
refusé bah suffit de regarder le doc
hein il y a beaucoup de il y a beaucoup
de documentaires qui sont faits par des
tas de gens qui sont des documentaires
très convenus avec l'aval de la
pénitentiare et mais je c'est pas un
reproche hein mais moi je sais de quoi
je parle quoi je sais ce que j'ai vécu
donc j'ai voulu vraiment montrer la
prison telle qu'elle est telle qu'elle
est vécue et puis surtout essayer de
sensibiliser les Français euh parce que
je pense qu'une partie de leur sécurité
se joue en prison voilà donc ça m'a
paraît très très important donc il y a
des images que l'on n jamais vu il y a
l'image d'un d'une livraison de drogue
par drog par drone ouis on l'a jamais vu
on va avoir des images vous allez voir
ça on va vous le montrer dans un instant
juste quelques questions c'est quoi le
plus dur en prison le loisiveté le le
fait que le temps le temps ne passe pas
ouais le temps ne passe pas c'est
d'ailleurs très très dommage parce que
tout tous ces aujourd'hui et je le
comprends les Français veulent mettre
tout le monde en prison c'est la réponse
à tout à à tous les problèmes on met en
prison mais est-ce qu'on se pose la
question de à quoi est utilisé ce temps
est-ce que ce temps est utilisé pour que
les gens sortent meilleurs ou ayant
appris quelque chose et malheureusement
pas et c'est là où il y a une
conséquence sur pour les pour les
Français c'est-à-dire que là on a vu
qu'il y avait encore eu des des des
règlements de compte à Marseille avec de
plus en plus de dommages collatéraux
hein donc ça ça ça passe comme ça c'est
ces gens qui font ça ils sont passés en
prison puisqu'ils ont tous un casier
judiciaire donc ils sont passés en
prison et ils sont ressortis et ils ont
recommencé ce qui montre bien que la
prison telle qu'elle est effectuée
actuellement est inefficace et grâce au
doc grâce au bouquin aussi que j'ai
écrit je je je j'essaie de d'envoyer un
message au français intéressez-vous aux
prisons parce que c'est votre sécurité
qui est en jeu et si vous ne vous y
intéressez pas les politiques ne s'y
intéresseront pas parce que ça rapporte
pas de voix alors donc ce documentaire
plusieurs détenus et ex détenus se sont
confiés ils ont notamment parlé des
téléphones euh selon eux quasiment tous
les détenus ont un téléphone en prison
regardez il y a même des gens qui
doivent avoir au moins trois ou quatre
téléphones dans leur cellues c'est
interdit effectivement mais comme vous
voyez bien sur les réseaux la plupart
sur TikTok surtout comme vous m'avez
trouvé la plupart ils ont tous des
téléphones on est on est à peu près 1100
détenus là où je suis on doit être allé
à 800 850 détenus avir téléphone je sais
que les survant ils savent très bien les
chefs ils savent très bien mais du
moment où tu fais pas le bordel avec ça
te portera pas
préjudice voilà alors c'est essentiel
d'avoir un
téléphone alors il y a il y a il y a
juste trois trois choses la première les
chiffre officiel de l'administration
pénitentiaire c'est 40000 téléphones
saisis par an et il y en a toujours
autant premier deuxièmement pourquoi
parce que le téléphone officiel le le
téléphone légal qui est fait par une
entreprise les Allemandes coûte pour un
détenu aux alentours de 300 € par mois
donc c'est juste impossible et la
troisième chose que je que je revenir à
mon à mon premier propos euh vous savez
qu'il y a eu malheureusement un
assassinat de professeur haras oui et on
a découvert que ce cet assassin était en
relation avec deux détenus au téléphone
dont un à la prison de la Santé
radicalisée prison dans laquelle j'ai
été il y a un an donc quand je dis que
les prison ce c'est la sécurité des
Français c'est la réalité il faut qu'il
faut vraiment que les Français en
prennent conscience l'administration
pénitentière a complètement lâché alors
dans ce documentaire vous évoquez aussi
le sujet des drones euh com vous n avez
dit il y a un instant de plus en plus
démocratisé regardez cette extrit en
plus qui m'a fait riree enfin qui m'a
fait rire regardez je suis en train de
regarder la télé je c comme tous les
soirs et là j'entends un drone qui
passe j'ai dit ah ouais ok ça va loin ça
va ouis ils sont forts hein franchement
ils sont très très forts mais moi en
tant que détenu je me dis c'est qui qui
s'est dit tiens je vais tester un drone
je l'embrasse hein il nous regarde tous
les soirs donc voilà donc c'est vrai que
ça c'est ça c'est c'est mon extrait
préféré du doc euh non franchement non
mais c'est c'est fou les drones c'est
c'est incroyable c'est incroyable c'est
un fléo alors on peut pas les arrêter
parce qu' il a avoir des filets il y en
a pas partout ça passe mais pour vous
vraiment c'est la nouvelle méthode de
livraison des drogues en prison c'est
très répandu les drones ou alors Gill
tant que c'est de la drogue qu'elle
passe par les parloirs qu'elle passe
d'une façon d'une autre oui mais
aujourd'hui la grande angoisse de la
pénitentiare c'est des armes oui c'est
que la prochaine la prochaine étape
c'est que des armes vont passer par des
drôes et la question que je pose c'est
va-t-il falloir qu'un surveillant soit
assassiné pour qu'on se rende compte de
ce qui risque de d'arriver donc la
prochaine étape c'est celle-ci et je
suis désolé hein c'est pas une étape qui
va arriver dans 10 ans c'est une étape
qui va arriver très rapidement les les
prisons sont peuplés de gens qui sont de
mauvais garçons et donc il y en a il y
en a on le voit il il y en a qui sont
radicalisés qui voilà qui qui veulent
sortir à tout prix il y a un gars qui a
pris 30 ans il veut sortir à tout prix
hein donc voilà oui oui clair vous
parlez du temps et et je suis d'accord
ce temps pourrait être vraiment utilisé
de façon bénéfique mais quelles sont vos
idées parce que vous pensez pas qu'un
développement personnel c'est personnel
et avoir envie de grandir avoir envie
d'apprendre d'évoluer c'est justement un
choix tell personnel qu'est-ce qu'on
pourrait faire justement de tout ce
temps selon vous CLA j'ai vu une
émission dans laquelle vous parliez de
votre propre cheminement et j'ai ça m'a
beaucoup touché puisque moi j'ai j'ai
vécu pratiquement le même mais
je voir la carrière je
dis d louper des trucser j'ai pas le
physique Cyr j'ai pas le physique mais
mais ni la souplesse mais choisi de pas
aller en prison mais alle mais non
essentiellement là encore je dis qu'il
faut que tous les les Français s'en
occupe c'estàdire que je pense que le je
suis pour qu'il y a une sanction et je
suis pour même que les gens restent en
prison le soir mais la journée vraiment
je pense que si on avait des gens des
boulangers qui s'occupent qui acceptent
de de donner un métier des agriculteurs
voyez mais des agriculteur ou le le ah
oui le les former dans la vraie vie oui
mais surtout que les les détenus
seraient apportés pas de salaire rien il
serait apporté pour apporter des des des
aides aux artisans un détenu dans une
cellule ça coûte 100 € par 100 € par le
problème c'est
l'évasion non l'évasion je vous assure
une chose Clara vous laissez la porte
ouverte il y a 90 % des détenus qui la
prennent pas parce qu' retour non non
non parce qu'ils ont pas envie mais je
comprends ce que vous dites et en plus
c'est passionnant et effectivement vous
expliquez bien quand finalement la la
prison fabrique de la délinquance qui
est encore pire quand elle ressort la
deuxième fois mais malgré tout nous ici
on on commande souvent des décisions de
justice et on dit tout le temps l'xisme
laxisme laxisme oh là là il est sorti la
prison vous vous rendez compte un
récidiv tout ça donc en fait ce que vous
dites j'entends mais est-ce que vous
pensez que les Français sont capables de
l'entendre et de l'accepter oui je pense
qu'il faut leur expliquer parce a du
karting en prison bah je pense que les
Français ça les vénère en fait donc non
non ils ont raison ils ont raison je
suis tout à fait opposé à ça je suis
tout à fait opposé à ça je vous le dis
franchement je suis tout à fait opposé à
ça en revanche je suis pour que les
détenus moi je suis pour que les détenus
aillent dans les hôpitaux par exemple
aillent dans les personnes agés mais
retourne en prison le soir les détenus
les
trafiquants -moi mais là je suis très
représentatif des des détenus j'en suis
pas fier d'ailleurs mais moi tout ce qui
est délinquant
sexuel crime de sang ça je parlais pas
en prison voilà donc je je je je
franchement ça pour moi je voilà j'ai un
discours qui j'ai un discours qui est
très vraiment un discours détenu je
pense qu'il y a des classifications à à
faire là encore l'administration ne veut
pas les faire donc on mélange tout
puisque je l'ai dit lors de la dernière
émission j'étais avec le complice de
l'assassin de Samuel pati je vois pas ce
que j'avais à faire avec lui mais ou
avec un cannibal ou bon peu importe
c'est pas grave mais mais je suis pour
que cette classification existe et c'est
très important parce que nous on pense
que c'est le cas en fait c'est pas du
tout le cas inroable c'est pas du tout
le cas un voleur est avec un violeur oui
bien sûr bien sûr et et avec un dealer
et ainsi de suite et d'ailleurs dans
dans le doc il y a un il y a il y a un
un détenu qui explique bien comment il
est arrivé à la grande délinquence en
prison mais pour pour revenir je pense
vraiment que les petites peines doivent
non pas être aménagé je pense et je
disais ça par rapport à Jacques la
dernière fois il faut qu'il y ait une
sanction qui soit à la prison mais c'est
le problème c'est qu'est-ce qu'on fait
en prison et là les les les les les gens
qui ont voir la gentillesse de regarder
ce doc ou qui vont la gentillesse de de
lire mon livre vont s'apercevoir que le
temps en prison ne sert à rien et je
pense que les Français ils sont tout
sauf bêtes tout sauf bêtees ils ont des
yeux ils regardent et ils disent mais
les gars ils ressortent ils recommencent
ça sert à quoi donc mis à part le fait
de nous faire plaisir et de dire il va
en tôle ok il ressort il ressort et le
but de la société c'est qu'il ressorte
autrement et nous devons tous alors moi
je suis un très mauvais exemple puisque
je suis un délinquant mais financier
mais donc je nous devons tous avoir
cette tâche et de dire comment je peux
faire est-ce que je peux pas prendre un
mec et et puis autre chose par exemple
vous avez des des des gens comme bigfo
et Olly orels n Jul
orels
vous avez tout cette jeun cette jeune
génération d'acteurs il devrait aller
une demi-journée en prison pour leur
parler alors ce documentaire vous éz de
la drogue en prison et certains détenu
ou détenu déclare qu'elle est
complètement toléré regardez à
l'extérieur en fait Contin Contin pas
dire que c'est légal mais c'est c'est
toléré pour que les déten violents ne
soi pas très violent et pour que ceux
qui sont trop excités il les laissent
tranquillees en fait ils vivent leur vie
sans leur prendre la tête à
eux voilà donc ça c'est c'est un extrait
assez fort pourquoi la drogue elle est
autant tolérée en prison bah non mais là
enfin là encore je je je je vous prends
un témoins vous enfin si vous avez un
endroit clos la drogue rentre de tous
les côtés si vous voulez la sortir vous
la sortez donc c'est toléré je je
compare souvent l'administration
pénitentiaire à l'éducation nationale
avant l'intervention de Gabriel Atal
c'est la règle de pas de vague il faut
pas de vague donc un détenu shoé ou un
détenu drogué ben c'est mieux qu' les
détenus prennent beaucoup de médicament
en prison ou pas énorme quoi
antidépresseurnifè peut-être pour dormir
je sais pas si je peux donner les
marques mais je peux je peux y aller
imovan voilàbovadre hypnol l'xom000 ça y
va quoi chose quiz vous pardon la
première fois oui la deuxième fois non
la première fois jeis en prison il y a
25 ans oui la deuxième fois non vous
dormiez la nuit ouais on va faire enfin
on dort avec le bruit ça c'est si le doc
le monte très très bien une prison une
prison c'est c'est tout le temps du
bruit du bruit du bruit tout le temps
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps c'est comme un match un match de
foot un public de foot avant un match
non vraiment ah ouais quoi il y a
toujours un ouais c'est impossible de
dormir voilà c'est comme ça il y a des
rats
il y a tout ça c'est non mais il y a
tout mais là là voyez je veux Cyril je
veux pas rentrer dans ce débatage je
vais t'expliquer pourquoi parce que il y
a des rats il y a des gens qui n'ont pas
d'argent aujourd'hui la vie est très du
pour les Français et et il y a des gens
qui ont des des des des problèmes
d'hygiène dans le dans leur immeuble
dans leur immeuble et tout ça et ils ont
rien fait donc je vraiment je veux pas
rentrer dans ce dans ce dans ce débat là
à la limite on a fait des erreurs on les
paye il y a des rats on il y a des
punaises il y a tout ça bon ok je répète
aujourd'hui malheureusement c'est c'est
le quotidien de beaucoup de Français non
ce que je je ce que je souhaiterais
c'est qu'il voit la réalité de la prison
qu' prenne conscience que ça ne sert à
rien qui prennent conscience également
que c'est un état un endroit de non
droit c'est c'estd c'est un endroit où
normalement on met des gens qui ont pas
respecté la loi donc elle devrait être
respectée à l'intérieur absolument
personne ne la respecte et et et ensuite
qui qui disent qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire comment on va faire autrement je
vous évoquez aussi le sujet des des
règlements de compte et de la violence
en prison pour certains cette violence
est inévitable regardez BAGAR BAGAR de
groupe BAGAR en cellule ça m arrivé des
fois le COD détenu enfin il est de
mauvaise humeur il parle mal avec sa
bouche la prison c'est un endroit où il
y a pas d'issu avec des murs quatre mur
tu es enfermé 22h sur 24 au bout d'un
moment quand vous côz quelqu'un pendant
3 4 5 voire 6 mois il y a des tensions
qui peut se créer pour n'importe quoi
pour une cigarette pour une feuille bah
du coup il parle mal je parle mal au
bout d'un moment ça reste la prison
c'est un cercle où il y a beaucoup de
violence du coup bah la violence reprend
le dessus j'ai évité au maximum mais des
fois il y a il y a pas le choix
c'est il faut écouter le 22h/ 24 ça veut
dire quelque chose imaginez-vous 22h/ 24
enfermé dans un endroit où vous avez
vous avez rien quoi est-ce qu'il y a des
pays où ils réussissent à appliqueres
ces règles essayer de de former les les
les prisonniers de leur apporter quelque
chose est-ce qu'il y a un meilleur
modèle ailleurs sur lequel on pour Suède
Norvège danemarque tous les pays du Nord
d'ailleurs je crois que je pense pas
révéler quelque chose mais je pense que
la chaîne va avoir de me confier
justement après avoir fait le constat
c'est ça d'avir de me confier quelles
sont les solutions exactement qu'on vous
souhaite parce que ça ferait du bien à
tout le monde y a beaucoup d'agression
en prison énorme agression de
surveillant agression entre détenus
énorme absolument énorme mais c'est le
monde de la violence c'est le monde de
la violence mais il y a il y a des
protections de certaines personnes
vis-à-vis de des surveillants et cetera
ou alors très très honnêtement il y a
l'isolement oui donc ça l'isolement oui
mais on on peut pas il y a une règle qui
fait qu'on peut pas rester à l'isolement
trop trop longtemps et la prison si on
veut vous trouver on vous trouve voilà
donc ça franchement si on veut vous
trouver on vous trouve si on veut faire
rentrer quelque chose on le fait rentrer
ouais voilà ouais vous vous avez une
protection vous avez une protection
particulière ou pas du tout j'ai eu
pendant les 15 premiers jours j'ai
trouvé ça assez ridicule parce que les
détenus se rappelaient de ce que j'avais
fait pour eux et j'ai dit je raconte ça
dans le livre je je croise le directeur
de la prison et je lui dis écoutez je
trouve que c'est ridicule je me balade
avec trois HX et trois arm avec des je
trouve ça ridicule je risque rien et il
me dit ici c'est pas vous qui décidez
monsieur boton très bien oui est-ce que
quel est le type de délinquence et quels
sont les quel est le type de délinquent
pour lequel vous seriez plus conciliant
pour aller dans le sens de votre
raisonnement on a bien compris que tout
ce qui relevait du bah oui mais c'est
alors tout ce qui est tout ce qui est
dél routier bien sûr parce que là aussi
je veux dire quelque chose non non non
non attendez je veux dire quelque chose
c'est là où c'est compliqué à entendre
non non attendez attend tout dépend du D
routier s y un meurtre nonou voilà si
s'il y a mais je veux dire au français
une autre chose c'est qu'on pense que la
prison n'arrive pas qu'aux autres h et
ça c'est faux car aujourd'hui avec les
délir routiers ça arrive aux autres on a
tous des enfants qui vous savez que je
crois que c'est un chiffre 30 % des
adolescents ont touché à la drogue un
problème avec un dealer vous savez pas
ce qui peut arriver un problème en
sortant de de de boîte de nuit ou de
truc un problème sur la route la route
vous vous faites une queue de poisson le
gars sort vous pas ce qu' peut r
l'alcool la conduite sous stupéfiant je
veux pas parler d'un cas voilà qui et
mais il ça présente combien de personnes
tous ces déles mineur c'est la majeure
partie franchement Franch oui oui bien
sûr c'est la majeure partie tout ce qui
est lié à la drogue c'est la majur
sachant qu'on dit que il manque à peu
près 20 % de place en prison
actuellement en France beaucoup plus
dans dans les films et dans les séries
on voit toujours que les détenus même
modèles se font inévitablement tabasser
est-ce que c'est une réalité ça Quiché
non c'est qu'on se fait pas toujours
tabasser non si on veut si on veut pas
se faire tabasser on se fait pas
taabiser voilà c'est c'est c'est c'est
une règle de société très dure très
violente mais vous pouvez être menacé
hein voilà moi j'ai j'ai eu cette
fois-ci peur pour ma sécurité vous n'y
retournerez plus du coup on va essayer
va essayer on va on va essayer Clara on
va essayer je vous le souhaite on va
Esser on va l'occuper il va faire des
docs il
va on va essayer ça qu'on lui donne du
travail remarquez j'y retourne tous les
25 ans Clara donc la prochaine fois non
mais non non mais quoi il y a eu quoi
toi Pierre quoi tu t'es fait t'es fait
emmerder ah oui oui par des par des gens
qui étaient radicalisés ou ouais ou par
des gens qui radicalisé j'ai j'ai
entendu quelque chose et j'ai je ne l'ai
pas admis ouis et j'ai pas compris je
l'ai pas admis et je oui oui bien sûr
j'ai j'ai été clairement menacé par des
des détenus radicalisés voilà bon de les
deux frères non pardon de frères non
ouais c'est c'est c'est pas important
mon cas personnel vraiment mon cas
personnel est peu important je suis là
tout va bien ce qui est important c'est
que les Français prennent conscience de
de de ce qui se passe et de surtout
qu'ils agissent par rapport à la à leur
sécurité par tu parlais de
radicalisation en prison les chiffres
sont impressionnants mais la question
que tout le monde se pose c'est est-ce
que le système carcéral en fait on fait
assez pour pour éviter tout cela
regardez un détenu nous raconte un gar
il est on le sait qu'il est rentré là il
est fichier s il est radicalisé le chef
de bâtiment il vient nous demander
carrément à nous à les détenus de
surveiller un peu ces gars on est parti
voir le chef on lui a dit écoutez lui il
il commence à endoctriner les autres et
ils l'ont pris ils l'ont sorti de notre
étage ils l'ont mis dans l'étage des des
plus faibles encore oh [__] malheur au
bout de 3 mois ils ont transformé la
salle d'activité en mosquée par la
caméra les sur ils voyaient tous ils
sont tous habillés à leur tenue
traditionnelle ils sont dit il se passe
un truc et ils sont allés voir ils ont
tous chopé en train de faire la prière
voilà ça c'est un des moments les plus
impressionnants auquels j'ai assisté
c'était un été donc comme je l'ai dit
une prison c'est énormément énormément
énormément énormément de bruit et
notamment le soir vers 20h et à 20h il y
a eu les premières notes d'un appel à la
prière donc avec d'énormes baffles donc
il faut savoir que c'est on doit savoir
d'où ça vient quand même et c'est très
très impressionnant parce que vous avez
le brou donc comme dans un stade
imaginez-vous un stade avant avant une
un match de foot et la première note
c'est le silence c'est plutôt bien tout
toute la toute la toute la toute la
toute la prison se tait quelque chose
qui est respecté alors vous avez aussi
demandé vous avez aussi demandé un
détenu comment il faisait pour avoir des
relations sexuelles en prison regardez
pas çaour en prison c'est tout un art on
a 45 minutes ou 15 minutes avant la fin
je sais qu'il va faaire sa deuxème ronde
j'ai ce petit créneau là il faut y aller
on avait demandé un CIN exprès il y a
une ouverture au niveau de de sec et
elle met sa robe ou une jupe ou même un
short peu importe elle rentra elle se
met soit elleève son short elle reste en
collant ou soit elle reste en jupe après
des fois des fois comme moi je me suis
fait attraper en train de faire Laour
mais le survient il me me connaît
franchement il ma dit ça se fait pas
mais ne recommence pas et bon bien sûr
que je suis dans un monde d'interdit
comment tu peux me dire ne pas
commommencer c'est incroyable ça alors
comment ça comment ça se passe qu'on a
pas on a pas bien compris euh on parloir
c'est c'est pas c'est c'est pas quelque
chose de nouveau de savoir qu'il y a des
bébés parloir c'est mieux ça plutôt que
se droguer euh oui ça dure moins
longtemps non mais donc au parloir c'est
c'est c'est c'est c'est courant alors ce
que ça c'est ce que j'ai pas pu le
filmer mais j'ai pu je le raconte dans
dans le livre en fait il y a plusieurs
techniques vous dites c'est mon ami qui
vient donc vous vous dites au
surveillant le regardant droit dans les
yeux vous lui dites aujourd'hui c'est
c'est mon ami qui vient donc vous le
regardez bien droit dans les yeux soit
il vous dit ok donc ça veut dire qu'il
accepte et je dois dire forcément la
plupart des surveillants acceptent euh
soit il vous dit ben
oui oui ça m' c'est pas important et
puis ensuite il y a une vraie solidarité
entre détenus donc quand vous dites à
aux détenus qui sont avec vous en
parloir c'est des petites cabine he vous
dites ben aujourd'hui c'est ma copine
ben il y en a un qui va sans doute
demander quelque chose au surveillant à
un moment et essayer d'attirer la les
surveillants le temps que enfin je je
dis très honnêtement très peu de détenus
le font parce que ils trouvent que ce
n'est pas respecter leurs femmes c'est
ça ouais voilà très peu hein franchement
très peu très peu le font il y en a qui
le font d'autant plus que maintenant
dans toutes les prisons dans la plupart
des prisons il y a ce qu'on appelle un
parloir famille
et on peut avoir on peut avoir accès à
ça mais généralement on réserve tous ça
plutôt à nos enfants à être avec nos
enfants et il y a des histoires d'amour
ou pas en prison oui bien sûr il y a des
histoires d'amour de tous les côtésou
donc tout tout ce que tu peux imaginer
Cyril il y a ah ouis c'est vrai ou c'est
médical médical détenu détenu
surveillant surveillant surveillant
détenu détenu tout ce que tu peux
imaginer a c'est c'est un endroit c'est
un endroit clos et c'est un
endroit tout tout ce que tu peux
imaginer il a ah c'est fou ah ouais il y
a d'ailleurs de très très belles
histoires visiteur de prison visiteur de
prison
détenu voilà avocat avocat tout à fait
JeanMichel
avocat ça ça c'est souvent avocat avocat
avocat détenu ouii ça arrive très très
souvent monsieur non vraiment tout ce
que tu peux imaginer laisse laisse libre
cour à ton imagination tu peux y aller
non non t'inquiète ton mer et toi toi
non toi jamais non non tu pas tuta pas t
tombe amoureux même pas d'un moi j'avais
j'ai perdu mais j'avais ah ou j'avais en
prison et j'ai perdu en prison ah ouais
d'c je le raconte dans le livre
d'ailleurs parce que c'est une chose qui
est importante ah oui c'est ça c'est
c'est important c'est c'est très très
important de savoir que parfois les
familles les familles les relations se
disloquent en prison c'est difficile
mais c'est comm ça c'est quoi ça s'est
terminé parce que tu étais en
prison ça s'est terminé parce que c'est
je préfère que je préfère que les gens
lisent le livre c'est c'est c'est plus
facile tu veux de l'écrire que de le
raconter c'est la chute du livre non non
c'est pas la chute mais c'est c'est vrai
ouais c'était compliqué non c'est
quelqu'un que tu connais d'A je sais je
sais ah oui je sais mon pire euh bon ben
on te retrouve ce soir pardon c'est ce
soir juste après tes PMP euh vraiment
c'est du très très lourd franchement je
l' regardé dè ce soir mon merci mon
Pirot d'être venu nous voir merci de
avec toi dans un instant